Miss Sherman, the thought of leaving my obituary to chance...
...is completely unreasonable to me.
Well, I am the obituary writer...
...so when the time comes, I will be writing your obituary.
I want you to write it now.
Here's the names of a few hundred people.
My name is Anne Sherman.
I'm from the Bristol Gazette.
I'd like to talk to you about Harriet Lauler.
Now, the deceased should be loved by their families.
There's an ex-husband, he's a jackass.
As I live and breathe!
Well, from the looks of it, I'm not sure you do.
The deceased must have touched someone's life.
I hated her so much.
When I was a kid, I loved the radio.
I'd like the job as disc jockey.
And what kind of music would you play?
The right question would be,...
..."What would I play after I play The Kinks."
And who is this?
It's my intern.
Whaddup?
Did I just lose my job to a hundred-year-old woman?
This is Harriet Lauler saying, "Please don't have a nice day."
I don't know if I can write your obituary.
I'm just not ready to close this chapter of my life.
Have a day that matters.
Have a day that's true.
Punch it!
Have a day that means something.
Harriet, you're a piece of work.
I am who I am.